[Music]
October 3rd 1997 9:45 p.m. 32 miles away
from the nation's capital Columbia
Maryland hi how'd you know with me
they've call ID I was at a Linda Tripp
Linda Tripp an aide at the Pentagon is
calling a 23 year old co-worker named
Monica Lewinsky tripping Lewinsky a
former White House intern worked
together in the Pentagon's Public
Affairs Office despite their age
difference the two women are close
friends Lewinsky is troubled about a
recent relationship yeah how do you want
to talk about it hate his behavior at
time this is no ordinary romance
Lewinsky is talking about an affair with
the President of the United States
William Jefferson Clinton is eight and a
half months into his second term his
public approval rating is at fifty five
percent it is a prosperous time in
America
stock prices are soaring jobs are
plentiful and the country is not at war
at the same time the Clinton presidency
is operating under a cloud of scandal
for the last three years an independent
council Kenneth Starr has been
conducting several investigations
related to the president what triggered
the investigations they began with
allegations of misconduct in an Arkansas
real estate deal
between 1978 and 1992 Bill and Hillary
Clinton were partners with two others in
the Whitewater Development Corporation
in 1992 allegations surfaced that the
Clintons may have profited illegally
from the venture in January 1994
Attorney General Janet Reno appoints a
prosecutor to investigate the so-called
whitewater case against the Clintons 7
months later he is replaced by Kenneth
Starr over the next three years other
unrelated allegations against the
president surface accusations of
campaign finance abuse the mishandling
of legal files and the improper firing
of White House staffers
you